Okay.
So I want to set up on a,
a new topic today.
Uh,
and to get us started,
I thought we'd play a game.
So the game is going to be cold cash in a Hass and we'll see what this game is
like in a minute.
So the idea is this,
that we to Paez,
I'm gonna pick on two of you,
I hope.
I hope I can find people who brought some money to class.
All right,
so play a one.
We'll have a choice.
Play a one can put nothing,
$1 or $3 into a hat.
The hat will then be given to play a two.
Okay.
And play a two can look at what's in the hats and either she can match what's in
the hats.
I add the same amount in.
So one,
if it's one or three of its three or she can simply take the cash.
Yeah.
All right.
The payoff,
this game will be as follows,
right?
Play a one.
If they put nothing in,
they're not going to get in the thing.
If they put one in and it's matched,
then they double their money.
So they get to back.
If they put three in at it's matched,
then they double their money.
So they get six backups,
they'll net three.
Uh,
however,
if they put one in and play a two takes it,
they've just lost their dollar.
I,
if they put $3 in and play a two takes it,
they've lost $3.
Hi Ron.
Everyone understand that?
Pretty simple from player to his point of view.
Uh,
if play a two matches,
then they get them their investment back plus a dollar 50.
If they matched one look at two 50 back at all and they get their investment
back plus $2 if they match three.
So that's if they,
if they get five back at all.
And of course if they sent me to take the money out of the hat and put it in
their pockets,
then that's what they get in the game.
I just,
once again,
if play a two matches with $1,
$1 and a half and she matches,
then she gets back to 50 for a profit of one 50.
If there's $3 and g matches three,
she gets back five for a profit of two.
And if she simply takes the money out of out of the hat and puts it in her
pocket,
then she gets how much money was in the hat.
All right,
so I hear will be the provider of the hat.
We'll use the same hat we use before and if necessary I provide sheets of paper.
We can write IOUs on front.
I'm hoping we can play for real cash.
Uh,
later on.
We could.
Nice to get a chair here.
But for now,
let me just go down here
and I'm going to grab this mic.
All right.
Who here wants to be player one?
Who brought some money to class today?
I'm quite willing to pick on somebody.
All right,
good,
good.
So play a one is,
uh,
what's your name again?
Justin.
To hold them to that hat for a second.
All right.
And uh,
who wants to be player too?
All right.
So this gentleman here,
his name is Nate.
Nate's.
All right,
we have Justin in Nate's.
All right.
So Justin,
you have to decide how much money you're going to put in the hat.
Did you make some money tonight?
But to make sure you have always borrow some from your neighbors.
All right,
I'm going to put in a buck.
All right.
All right,
so the money's been put on the hat and delivered to a knife.
It's,
I'm going to put in the buck tears that I get.
All right?
So if we empty out the hat,
here's our beautiful pink cat.
Really had the hat passed across the room rather than have me do it,
but we have $2 on the hats.
So I'm going to pay each,
I'm going to pay a,
what am I going to pay?
I'm gonna pay player a one,
a $2 I got to give back to the original dollar and give them to in a second and
I'm going to play play a to a dollar 50 you just hold the hat.
We'll do that for the $2 and 50 when you get your money back.
Trying to cheat.
You hear me?
All right,
so play.
I'll get you the rest of the second.
I got a second for now.
It's your double the money.
All right.
Here.
This is one reason to take this classes and you play while you get money.
All right,
now let's just try again.
so we had one round of this.
It's to have another round horse will be player one now.
All right,
so Katie is buyer one.
can you bring some money?
All right.
And who wants to be pled to further away?
Um,
uh,
Steven,
isn't it that right?
So Steven's going to be player too and he brings him cash?
I think so.
All right.
Otherwise borrow it from your neighbors.
I can have IOUs here.
So here's the hands.
You got coins.
Ah,
ah.
All right.
All right,
well putting,
okay,
great.
So to post that,
post that down,
we'll see if it makes it that just the honesty of the classic
working its way down.
I'm gonna have to,
we go,
here we go.
Oh,
we're down to Steven.
Okay.
Check how much is in there.
You can decide whether they match or not,
or is it Steven's going to match as well?
All right.
Once again,
we have this time rather annoyingly a dollar and some coins in here,
which I will empty on the stage to prove to everybody.
All right?
And I will,
I will.
All right,
North Koreans in here throwing matches in a second and give it back to you guys,
right?
Everyone understand the game?
All right.
Ever understand how this game works.
So we're gonna spend a while discussing this and we'd go and playing.
He said eventually lose so much money.
I'm going to run out of lunch money.
Put Ca's would objects.
All right.
So what I want to do is I want to analyze this game.
I want to think about what this game's about.
What's really going on here?
All right,
so first,
this is just a little game in both putting some money in a hat,
but I want to suggest to you that this is a,
a toy version of a much more important game.
This is a toy version of a game involving a lender and the borrower.
So you could think of our player ones here.
That was Katie on the second round.
And uh,
Justin on the first round and Justin on the first round as I imagine them
working in an investment bank or perhaps in a venture capitalist firm,
right.
And what they're doing is they're giving a loan to somebody,
some budding who's come up with a new project.
So Steven in round two and who is my budding entrepreneur in round one?
What was your name?
Nate.
In round one,
I've come up with some budding products that they've left Yale perhaps after
their junior year.
They doesn't know they've left early cause they've got some great idea for
something which is going to make the millions who either it's a new mouse trap
or a new version of Facebook or something and they go to the,
oh,
that's hard,
isn't it?
To something better than the new version of Facebook.
Right.
And they go to the,
there's venture capitalist firm,
uh,
maybe it's some firm in New York or maybe it's the Yale Investment Trust,
whatever.
And they explain this great idea to them and they asked for some money to invest
in this firm,
to buy machinery and to pay early wages and so on.
All right.
And the lender,
the lender,
the Buckeye works,
the venture capitalist firm has to decide how much money to invest in this
project.
Right after having a off.
This money has been invested in the projects.
The person who borrowed it face these choices,
they could go forward with that project,
work hard,
spend the money on the things they're supposed to span,
or they could just disappear to Mexico.
All right.
Go back to Yale for that matter.
And there's actually something in between they could do,
which is less romantic than disappear into Mexico.
They could just not work particularly hard shirk perhaps join joining someone
else's projects and just let the money run down without the lender really
knowing about it.
Alright.
So this is a very real problem that some of you,
if some of the budding entrepreneurs in the room are going to face when you
leave gale and more of you who are going to end up working for investment banks
apps unfortunately are going to face as well.
All right.
Okay.
So gonna spend the whole of today analyzing this,
but before we even start,
let's notice that there's something different about this game.
Other than that sheer triviality.
There's something different about this game than games we've played all the way
up to the midterm so far.
What's different about this game?
What's different?
Yeah.
Can I um,
can I get a mic in here?
Sorry.
Ah,
yes.
What's different?
Moves aren't simultaneous.
The moves and not simultaneous.
This is a sequential move game and put the rules up here
and bring this down.
So for the first time we're looking at a sequential
move game.
I'm waiting to spend most of the rest of the term looking at sequential move
game where it needs to kick games that involve sequential elements.
Now,
what's really what makes this as sequential move game,
let's be careful about this.
What makes it as a sequential move game is not simply that pile one moved first
and play out two moved second.
Although that's true.
What really made this a sequential move game is that play to knew what player
one had done before he got to make his move.
Right?
It isn't the timing per se that matters.
It's going to turn out.
It's the fact that player to could observe player one's choice before having to
make his or her choice that matters.
And notice just while we're on the subjects more than that,
play a one knew this was going to be the case.
All right,
so let's get that down.
Sorry.
In this game,
play at two news.
Hello Ari.
One's choice
before she chooses she being planned to four p let's play before two chooses.
Alright.
And second play on one
news that this
will be the case.
Yeah.
And the way we dramatize this just now is play a one.
Put the money in the hat.
The hat was transported across the classroom with people.
Very honestly not stealing the money to play a,
to play a two could look in the hat,
could see how much money was in there before Steven or Nate had to make that
choice.
Is that right?
All right,
so how do we go about analyzing games that have this sequential structure?
So turns out that a useful way to analyze them on the way I want to get us used
to today already is to draw a tree.
So the first half of the cost,
we'd do a lot of matrices.
Now we're going to draw trees.
And for those people who haven't seen trees before,
not a big deal.
It's an object that looks like a tree.
That's why it's called a tree.
All right,
so let's have a look during this particular game.
Here is player one making her choice and in fact she has three possible choices.
She can put nothing one or three into the hat.
All right?
Play a two then chooses,
well,
they're really pay a two only has choices to make if there's the money in the
hat and play a two has two choices in this particular game.
Any of the case,
I the player two is going to add a dollar or $3 into the hat or they're going to
disappear off to Mexico taking our investors lunch money with them.
All right and let's put down the payoffs.
So let's put down as pay offs.
The net gains they make.
All right,
so if nothing goes in,
no one makes any money.
So zero,
zero be the payoff.
If one is matched by one,
then the investor,
the lender doubles her money to do make a net profit of one.
If if uh,
if the money is taken out by a Plat to then she loses one right down here.
If she,
if if two matches her investment of three,
she gets an she doubled her money again.
So makes a net profit of three and if the money is taken out,
she loses three.
Everyone all right with that,
let's do play a tos payoffs.
Yeah.
In the case in which he in which he matches one,
he makes a net profit of one 50 in the case in which he just steals the one,
he makes a net profit of one and down here in the case where he matches three,
he makes a net profit of two.
He gets five back that he did arrested three to start with.
And here if he just takes the money out,
he makes a profit of three.
All right,
so this game,
it's just a illustrated on the board.
And for some of you,
this is the first time you've seen a tree.
But I'm going to claim it isn't such a it isn't it a complicated object.
And we could a lot of time analyzing this in terms of connected graphs and so
on,
but it isn't really worth it.
It's just a tree.
All right?
Okay.
So let's just make sure we understand that the payoffs here represent,
play a ones,
pay off and play a two page twos payoff
respectfully.
All right,
so how do we analyze what to do in these games?
It's a good idea always to write up the tree.
They get a good idea to write up the matrix,
but how to analyze what we should do.
One,
before we do that,
let me just grab the mic and find out from our,
from our players what they should do.
All right.
All right,
so where are,
where was my first investor?
All right,
so Justin,
why,
why do you put $1 in there of a $1 in Houston incentive to put $1 into,
they're putting $3.
She's just going to take the money and run.
All right.
Okay,
so,
so what's,
what's just enduring,
Justin is looking forward if you like,
he's putting himself in play or two shoes.
This was uh,
who was our investor are receive and Nate,
Nate,
Nate shoes,
and anticipating what needs going to do.
And as Justin said,
if he puts in three,
Nate's going to have an incentive to take the money and run.
In fact,
what would need have done it and made it.
If three had been in the hat,
what would you have done?
Um,
I like Justin,
but I would have taken the money.
All right.
Even though,
you know,
Justin,
you'd taken the money and disappeared somewhere.
We don't quite know.
Right,
right.
It's the same.
True for PR for the other past.
So it's okay.
You also put one in,
is that your explanation as well?
Same reasoning.
Okay.
So everyone figured out what was going on I wanted to get,
and we think probably that's try Steven.
If it'd been $3 on a hand or what do you have done?
I would've taken it and taken it.
All right.
So yeah,
so we basically getting what the,
what's predicted here,
uh,
out of the game.
All right.
And let's just see that more formally,
that idea.
So the idea here is that the players who move early on in the game should do
something we've always talked about before.
They should put themselves in the shoes of the other players.
But here that takes the form of anticipation,
right?
That anticipating what players down the tree are going to do.
All right.
So the key idea here is anticipation.
Yeah.
All right.
Well they're going to do is they're going to look down the tree.
Imagine themselves in the shoes of the later players.
Look at the incentives facing those later players.
Imagine that they do the best they can.
There's better players do the best they can and then walk backwards through the
tree.
So the key idea here is to look forward,
look forward to the end of the tree and work back.
Look forward and work back.
All right.
And that's exactly exactly the process that Katie and Justin described
themselves as doing
right now in this tree.
Let's have a go at this.
So let's imagine ourselves in Steven or neat shoes having found as they did,
in fact,
having found $1 in the hat,
they then are making a choice between adding a dollar,
which nets to them a dollar 50,
or taking the dollar,
which nets them lets them one,
one 50 is bigger than one.
So we think they're going to go this way.
All right?
If we're happy with that.
Conversely,
if they found themselves with $3 in the Hass,
uh,
then if they add an $3,
they match.
They're going to get $2 they're gonna net $2 if they take the money out,
they're going to get away with $3 all right.
Three seems bigger than two so we think they're going to go this way.
I'm going to go with you.
We're assuming that these are better real payoffs.
Okay,
so from player one's point of view,
since player one of knows that player two we'll observe the toys before making
her own choice and since play a one can,
I can put him,
put him or herself in play or two shoes and anticipate this choice play a one is
essentially choosing between one.
If she puts in zero,
she gets zero.
If she puts in one,
she knows too,
we'll match and she'll double Hamani and get one.
And if she puts in three then she knows pay a two we'll take them on the Iran.
In which case I'll lender will have lost $3 so she's choosing between zero one
and minus three I'm just going to choose one
which is exactly what happened in the game.
All right,
everyone happy with how we did that?
Right?
So this idea of starting at the last player,
the player who moves,
lost,
solving out what they're gonna do,
and then working our way back through the tree has a name.
The name for this is backward induction.
Okay.
Am I apologize for the business school students in the room who've had this
habit into them too many times already?
So yeah,
apologize for them in advance.
Right?
Backward induction now turns out
is precisely one controversial thing about backward induction,
which is whether you should say backward induction or backwards induction.
So I'm going to leave the s off and call it backward induction.
But,
uh,
it's up you with which when you think of the correct English is
all right.
Okay.
So since we've got this game here,
let's talk about it a bit.
This idea of the lender and the borrower,
it's not an unimportant situations we've had,
we've simplified it down to a very simple choice here,
but it's a very basic choice out there in the real world.
All right?
And it's an important choice.
After all,
what keeps the economy running is the ability of lenders to lend money to
businesses that then invest them profitably and are able to make returns.
So there's this underlies a whole bunch of what a of staff going on in the
economy.
All right,
so let's talk about this in the first thing I want to talk about is I want to
point out that there's a,
there's a,
there's a problem here.
There's a,
there's a bad thing here.
Much like there was a bad thing in the very first class of the,
of the semester,
in the very first class of the semester.
The bad thing was a prisoner's dilemma.
All right?
But here it's a little different,
but that's focused on it awhile.
So the bad thing is we ended up here,
none of disaster.
All right?
The lender doubled her money.
The borrower was able to go ahead with the project on a small scale and make
some money.
The bad thing,
however,
is that we would have liked to end up.
Yeah.
All right.
Hi.
Don't,
we've been able to have a large projects funded with $3 and had the borrow,
uh,
repaid.
Those dollars are matched in effort or whatever happens to be,
then we'd end up at an outcome that is better,
not just for the lender.
It's obviously better for the landline,
but it's also better for the borrower.
Everyone see that?
So the outcome we'd like to have reached gets us against the lender three where
she's only getting one where we ended up and it gets the borrower to where he's
only getting one 50,
where we actually ended up.
Alright.
Why is it that we were unable to both of our pairs,
both Justin and Nate's and Katie and Steven.
Why will we unable to get to here or were unable to get to here?
They take us what got us well,
what prevents us from getting to this to this good outcome?
Let's go back to to Katie a second and see if we can,
yeah,
you go ahead.
Oh,
I'll come to right.
All right.
So Katie was saying why she invested one.
I picked on Justin before.
So,
so you know,
here's this good outcome.
It's better for you.
It's better.
Steven,
who's your,
who's your borrower?
Why aren't we getting to this three,
two outcome?
Because if I played three,
um,
him matching my money is dominated,
right?
Strictly dominating.
All right,
so the problem here,
the problem here is Katie would like to invest three if she knew that in fact
Steven was going to,
but she knows Steven's not going to match,
right?
Steven and facts,
it's gonna run off with the cash.
All right?
It's gonna end up being spent at Starbucks or something.
All right.
And for Steven's point of view,
he would actually like to be able to borrow the $3.
He would like to be able to end up at this three two outcome as well.
The problem is he knows,
and Katie,
he knows the key to load and Katelyn is the heroes,
but in fact he's going to run off with the cash.
Is that right?
All right.
It's worded a bit of a problem here.
We'd like to get this good outcome,
but incentives are preventing us from getting there.
What do we call this kind of situation?
What do you call this kind of problem?
Anybody
order takers?
All right.
This is called moral hazard.
This is called moral
hazard.
How many of you have heard the term moral hazard before?
All right,
number of people had it,
so here we are.
Moral hazard.
Here's the problem that the agents,
in this case,
the borrower,
the borrower hasn't set has incentives,
will have incentives to do things that are not in the interest of the principal.
All right?
If we're not careful and as as we would for example,
by getting too big alone,
the incentives of the borrower will be such that they will actually not be
aligned with the incentives of Orlando and that will prove to be bad for the
lender.
But notice the existence of this moral hazard problem isn't only bad for the
It ends up being bad for the borrower as well.
All right,
let me give you another example.
In insurance,
does that class probably the classic moral hazard problem.
If an insurance company insures me against having my car stolen,
there's a moral hazard problem in that I animate.
Not if I,
if I,
if the car is fully insured,
I might now have the incentive not to bother to lock my car or to leave it
anywhere on the street in new haven.
All right.
Because I'm not bearing the cost and all right,
so we need you to be able to the insurance companies to worry about that in
writing an insurance contract for me and in practice what the insurance company
does is it forces me to take a deductible.
It doesn't allow me full insurance.
It makes sure that some of the costs of having a car stolen,
it's gonna fall on me.
That's bad for me by the way because it means I can't get full insurance.
Alright.
And there was just not what happened here is rather similar in this case,
both the lender and the borrow would rather have a big project,
a big loan and have the uh,
have the agent pay back that loan.
They'd prefer the streets you outcome,
but they can't get there.
And therefore rather than having a full scale projects KCO Justin only offered
the borrowers as small scale project.
All right,
so the idea here and this example was and this example,
okay,
what happened was we kept
the size of the project or the size of the loan.
You can think of this as the project if that borrowing something
small
to reduce
the temptation
to cheat.
Okay.
To reduce that temptation,
not to re not to repay the loan.
All right,
so these problems are all over the all over society but that particularly
prevalent in situations involving uh,
lenders and borrowers.
All right,
so a good question is how might we solve this problem?
A lot of you about to go out and try and borrow money to start your projects
that run your new version of Facebook would ever,
and a lot a lot more of your,
you said before going to end up loaning money,
perhaps someone else's money probably least for awhile.
And we want to know how you might solve this moral hazard problem.
We've seen one way to solve it,
one way or something to keep the size of the project small.
What else could we do?
We come down and try to have a discussion.
Okay.
What else could we do to Steven?
What else could we do?
You with a borrower,
what else can you like?
Uh,
impose laws.
We can impose laws.
Okay.
So we could impose laws much like we talked about in the prisoner's dilemma.
We can regulate this market.
There's going to be a little bit of a problem we're gonna run into,
in regulating the law,
uh,
in,
in using the lower here.
What's the problem we're gonna run into here?
I mean,
we do have laws that regulate borrowers and lenders.
What's the,
what's the law that regulates borrowers and lenders?
Bankruptcy law,
right.
So it,
We have,
we have law that regulates,
to some extent what lenders and borrowers can do.
One of things we do in that law is we limit the degree to which we're allowed to
punish the borrowers.
It's a bankruptcy law pretty much says we're going to put some limit on how much
Casey can inflict pain on Steven for running off with a bunch of money.
All right,
Steven,
can somebody say,
I can't repay.
I'm bankrupt.
You know,
he's more or less,
I've allowed at a fresh start.
So the Lord the Lord be good here.
But what does limits to what we can do?
Right?
We could go back to the Dickensian world of throwing Stephen in jail for not
repair,
not repaying the loan,
but it's tough.
There are downsides to that.
It turns out all right.
So what else?
What else could we do?
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm gonna have to dive in there a little bit.
So shout into the mic.
The venture capitalists can impose restrictions on what the person can do with
the money.
All right.
So,
so you could try and say,
ah,
there's only certain things you can do with the money and for example,
to make that credible,
what am I have to do is to say,
show me what you're going to do with the money.
Me The receipts.
Right.
I don't think you could say is I will,
I will only give you the money if you show me exactly how you're going to spend
this high.
That's a good,
that's a good solution.
No,
just that one you could,
you could regard that as changing the order of play writes a little bit like
saying let's have the borrower have to move first.
Let's have the borrower have to commit what their actions are going to be.
How are they going to spend the money before and shut your show the,
the,
the contracts before the,
before the lender lending the money.
Right.
And that's a good solution.
But again,
there are limitations to this solution.
What are the limitations to that solution in the real world?
Let's go back to one of you are thinking about making millions met with your new
Facebook.
What are the limitations to,
to uh,
having some contracts with that,
with,
with the bank,
with chase saying exactly how you're going to,
not only at saying exactly how you're going to spend the money,
but actually detailing it already with contracts ahead of time.
What are the problems with that?
Someone else was thinking of going into business here.
Let me pick on somebody a second.
So what's your name?
Say Kelly.
Kelly's what?
Imagine you have some projects you're going to,
you're going to borrow some money from chase or Mr Swenson to start this fun.
Why might you worry about having everything written out in contractually had to?
Yeah.
Um,
I mean,
then it restricts your freedom on what your ideas are,
I guess.
Right?
So one problem is that's just sheer lack of flexibility.
All right?
If,
if in fact the entrepreneur is not going to lead any,
it's not going to be flexible in how they actually run the project.
The North Point of being an entrepreneur in the first place,
right?
Yet there's a limit to how much control you want to give to the lender,
the lenders,
and really wanted to run the project for you,
right?
There's all sorts of their problem of timing you simply,
it's something not going to be possible to specify all the expenditures of a
project up front.
You're going to need some money to do some things ahead of time.
All right,
so it's a good idea.
Changing the order of play as a good idea,
but there's gonna be limitations to this.
What else could you do as the lender?
What else could you do?
Thank you for loaning some money in here.
Learning some money to one of your classmates for some project.
Let's try again.
Maybe like blowing money over time in stages and observed progress.
Good,
good.
So one possible he,
sorry.
One possibility is to break the loan up and give it and they come in small
installments.
If you do well on the first installment,
I'll give you a bigger installment next time.
All right.
I notice it's that.
That's a little bit like,
cause then we talked about the very first week.
It's a little bit like taking this one shot game and turning it into a repeated
game,
right?
It's tea,
it's turning a one shot interaction into a repeated interaction and we'll come
back and talk about repeated interactions later on in the course.
Again,
notice that the might be some limitations of that.
I mean,
I think it's a good idea and in general you should be trying to do this,
but it could just be that to set up for need to set up his new Facebook and for
Steven's up his new mouse trap factory.
They just need a chunk of money at the beginning.
There may be some limits to how little money you can give them at the beginning
since they have to hire workers and set up the factory and make some big splash
and advertising and so on and so forth.
All right,
so again,
it's a good idea,
but there may be limitations here.
What else could you do?
Let's have a look at the numbers on the board right now.
The numbers on the board say that if Steven's mouse trap projects,
we do the Facebook and the see if Steven's fact,
if even mouse trap project goes well and it ended up being a big project with
lots of money available.
There are five units of money available in profit,
right?
Three plus two.
All right.
The way we've,
the way we've designed things so far are Linda,
I gave you these payoffs in the game.
The lender is going to double her money.
She's going to get three,
six bactrim it to net three and Steven's going to get to,
so the division of that five is three and two
but we don't have to divide the money like that.
If you're a lender,
you may want to think about how you divide up the spoils of a successful
projects.
All right,
so how else could you divide up those $5 that three plus two in a way that might
be better for everybody?
Hey,
we invested $3 and 1 cent.
If they do that other choice and then take a little bit of a hit,
but that way you'll still have something that's pre to optimal to the other.
The other choice that we came to before,
all right,
I'm guessing you didn't hear that,
but that was right.
So we said that's exactly right.
So what you could do here is you could redesign the payoffs of this projects in
the event that it's successful.
All right?
What you could do is take these five units of profits and instead of having
three to try it in a different color,
we could give the the borrower,
the entrepreneur 3.1 leaving a 1.92 a the lender.
All right,
so we could change the payoffs of this contracts to be 1.9 3.1 in the event of a
big project.
Why does that help?
Because now our borrower needs,
or Steven,
where are they to end up with a hat with $3 in eds.
They now will find it's in their interest to match the,
the $3 and get 3.1 rather than three.
All right.
So what's,
this is an example of this,
is this,
this idea of changing the contracts to give the borrower incentives to repay
incentives,
not to shirk and not to disappear with the cash is an example of what's called
incentive design.
Hi.
The idea here is in all of businesses,
incentives are not given by God.
They're designed by the people who write the contracts.
All right?
And if you're in the,
you're uh,
either the borrower,
the lender,
you should be thinking about writing a contract that's going to achieve the end
that you want.
Now notice in this particular example exactly as Nate said,
the lender is going to take a bit of a hit here.
They're not going to get 100% return,
but the ending up doing better than they would have done by giving a small loan
high,
they've ended up getting 1.9 rather than one.
All right?
Then have a 1.9 rather than one.
So in this particular example,
it won't always be the case,
but in this example,
they're taking a smaller share.
Yeah,
a smaller share of a larger pie.
Okay.
And sometimes a smaller share of a larger pie is bigger than a larger share of a
smaller pie.
Not always,
but sometimes the reason the pie is larger is we're able now in incentive
compatible way,
we're able to go ahead and have a large projects.
So in this example,
the smaller share of the larger pie actually ended up being bigger than the
largest share of the smaller pipe.
So smart.
A smaller share of a larger pie
can be
bigger
van,
a large share.
Yeah,
all of a smaller pie.
Not always,
of course.
All right.
This is just an example.
Oh,
this must be a little bit careful here.
All right,
so this particular example,
even though this,
this 1.9 this return that our lender is able to make by accepting a smaller
share of a larger pie,
even though it's a bigger absolute return,
it's smaller in another sentence.
And what sense is it smaller?
Let's be careful here.
So what time did you say,
look,
it's 1.9 1.9 is bigger than one.
That's going to be a good thing.
But since some of you actually are going to go out and investment banks and you
might be posed this question,
let me just not let,
let me just make sure we don't make a blunder that's going to spoil your
interview.
So what,
what,
what might you be worried about as an investment banker about this deal?
About this,
about this,
this contract?
Somebody else.
Anybody else?
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll come down again.
All right.
What might you be worried about?
Who has the be honest?
Who here is in,
has been interviewing with either investment banks or venture capital firms or
private equity firms?
Raise your hands.
Oh,
come on.
It's getting more than that.
All right.
It was a hand a little bit.
What was the hand at the back of the hand?
Way Back here.
Hello?
Yeah.
Hello.
So what,
what,
what might be wrong with this project?
From your point you've actually taken,
it can kind of get on the mic on that side.
It's of my head.
What might be wrong w with the product from
your point of view,
if you could actually just find three small projects,
then you could still get 100% returns just by dividing it up.
Good.
You're going to get a lot.
You're going to be lots of money from Morgan Stanley or whatever it is.
Good.
[inaudible] name is Brian writes,
he's a good habitat and a could add to hire Brian Morgan Stanley.
All right.
All right,
so what,
what Brian said was it's true that you're making a bigger absolute return here.
This is a bigger absolute return,
but this return up here is 100% return on your capital.
The rate of return on capital is higher,
making 100% return on investment of one they're making a 1.9 return on
investment of three.
The rate of return is better in the in the,
in the smaller case,
so which is the right answer?
Should we worry about the rate of return but a hundred percent rate of return or
should we worry about the absolute return?
If you're in the business of investment banking,
who thinks you just worry about the absolute return?
Who thinks we just worry about the rates of return?
Who thinks it depends?
What does it depend on?
What does it depend on
to keep keep you from falling off this day?
What does it depend on?
Somebody you said it depends.
It depends on your good compromise voter.
You get [inaudible],
you know it depends on,
yeah,
the gentleman here.
Okay.
Since an investment banking firm only has limited amount of money to invest,
you want to see if you can get a higher rate of return investing elsewhere.
All right,
so so this to this,
I think you're on the right lines.
There's two things to worry about.
One is what is your supplier of funds to invest and the other is what's the
other supply you're worried about as it as an investment bank or venture
capitalists or private equity investor.
What's the other supply coming your way?
Yeah,
the number of projects coming across your door.
If you like the demand for your cafe,
the demand for your cash.
Let's apply of projects.
All right.
All right,
so the,
what we have to worry about here is what is the true opportunity cost of that
money.
All right.
If there are very few projects out there,
all right?
Then you basically just want to want to go down the list of projects picking off
absolute return.
However good.
The other extreme,
if there's an infinite supply of projects all coming in,
all of which will offer a hundred percent return.
Then is our banker at the back told us,
you should just go for three small projects rather than one large one.
Right?
But the question is questions of which is better,
three lights,
which isn't as simple as saying,
yes,
we should always go for three small projects that may not be free.
Small projects out there that offer 100% return.
All right,
so what's going to matter here is what's the true opportunity costs of the
capital,
and that's going to depend on what projects are available to you.
All right.
This was just an example of incentive design.
One example of incentive design.
Let's talk about other examples of incentive design.
So design,
it's been a lot in the news lately who,
who else tends to have incentive contracts other than borrowers?
Who else out that tends to have incentive contracts?
It's a big topic in the know in the news these days.
So who has an incentive contract incentives written into their contracts?
Yeah,
way over here.
Let me run over at the risk of blurring the camera.
All right,
so who else has an incentive?
My contract managers.
Managers.
All right.
So CEOs have huge incentive clauses in their contracts.
All right?
Sometimes in the form of options,
why do they have those incentive causes in that contract?
Well,
there's two interpretations of this.
One interpretation is it's just a bad thing or they're just trying to screw the
world,
but there's a more,
there's a more,
uh,
um,
moderate view of this.
The more moderate view of this is that those incentive clauses in their
contracts are attempts to align the interest of the managers with the interest
of the shareholders just as this contract is attempting to align the interest of
the and the interest of the borrower.
All right.
So by managers,
I took him to me and CEO,
but what other kinds of managers recently in the press very recently this
weekend,
how been talking about incentive contracts,
uh,
somebody way,
way over the Avnet caught on the wrong side as he's over.
Um,
yeah,
I can I just squeeze through,
I'll try and squeeze through.
Can I squeeze through?
Sorry.
All right,
sorry.
Here we go.
Where was it?
Where was,
where was my answer to that question?
Here we go,
man.
Who's a baseball teams just to manage managers.
A sports teams also have incentive contracts these days,
right incentives to to achieve certain levels.
All right.
Here it's not quite clear to me exactly what's going on.
Right?
We call those incentive contracts,
but you might want to worry a little bit.
I mean do we really think that the manager has an incentive to lose otherwise?
All right,
so let's talk.
Part of what's going on with this into contracts isn't actually incentive
contracts.
Part of it is about sharing the risk [inaudible] kind of contracts have been
written about over the weekend with Joe Torres contract for the gang gears,
which you turned down is partly perhaps to give them incentive to try and win,
but perhaps it's more to do with sharing the risk among the general manager and
the manager of the team if they don't make it to the playoffs,
but all right,
this one incentive contracts,
are we seeing incentive contracts elsewhere and we've seen them since the Middle
Ages,
right?
In the Middle Ages,
incentive contracts took a particular form and the form was called or two
things.
Peace Rights.
Put it up here.
I did agriculture.
It took the form of sharecropping.
Yeah.
What our piece rates.
Somebody want a piece rates.
What a piece rates.
Anybody,
anyone know anyone who's on piece rates?
What is sharecropping?
Somebody must be from a farming state.
There's not somebody out here.
The guy in orange.
Yep.
Um,
sharecropping is where the landowner takes a portion of the,
um,
of the farmers crop at the end of the,
at the end of the farming season.
All right.
So sharecropping is a contract whereby part of the output of the farm goes to
the landowner and part is kept by the farmer.
Got in the Middle Ages.
Part of the output would stay with the peasants and part of it would go to the
Lord of the manor.
Alright.
Peace rights or a similar idea rather than playing,
paying wages to workers,
just bundles of cash.
The amount of which they're paying depends on output.
So piece rates would say if you produce a 17 yards of cloth,
then you'll get paid.
Uh,
the,
the revenue that's derived from three of them say all right.
Both of these forms of contracting are that partly to create incentives.
They create incentives because they create the incentive of the farmer to
increase yields and then create incentives on the part of the worker to increase
output.
All right,
so piece rates are a big part of the story.
All right.
Sense of his lines are pretty big topic and we don't really have time to go into
it much in this course,
but it's worth mentioning that in fact,
the Nobel prize that was one last week by those three economists we talked about
was partly about incentive design.
All right?
It's regarded as an important enough topic for the design,
the design of incentives across the science as a whole to have been worthy of,
of winning the Nobel prize.
My guess is there's another Nobel prize.
It's going to come out in this same area in the next five or 10 years.
All right.
Just make it clear.
You can have problems.
You can bet,
you can write incentives badly.
It's classic story that you've all heard of.
I'm sure that in often in PA,
in the provision of public goods,
let's say bridges or highways or tunnels,
the incentives for the construction companies tend to be rather badly written.
They,
they're meant to have incentive clauses,
but they never seem to quite get them right.
It's easy to get these incentives wrong.
And just to prove this doesn't just happen to management.
Let me just tell a story against myself.
So a year ago,
a year we're going to go,
I was picking fruit with my then three year old daughter and I wanted to make
sure that we got some fruit home to eat for dinner and she didn't just eat all
the fruit as we picked it.
These were raspberries.
Uh,
so I decided to have a rule that sounds efficient.
I said,
well,
any,
any item of fruit that gets picked,
that's in good condition,
we'll take it home for dinner.
But if it's squashed then we'll go and we'll eat it then and there.
Or we're picking the fruit.
All right.
So my three year old procedures to go along the,
the uh,
bushes of Rosa is picking the Roseberry turning round to me and saying squashed
and putting it in her mouth.
All right.
Squashed.
Right,
which shows the three year old knows more than a professor about moral hazard.
Alright.
Alright,
so one thing we can do is worry about design in the design of the contract.
There's another thing we can do here.
Watch.
The other thing we can do here.
I mean we're missing out something very basic.
What is,
what is it that's that our borrower,
Steven and Nate's can do or putting more generally for all of you.
If you go out and start a company and you borrow some money to start your
company,
when you leave Yale,
what are you going to have to do?
What's the borrower?
Well,
what's the lender?
What's the bank grew incest or what are they going to assist on
anybody?
They got to insist on collateral.
They're going to insist on collateral.
What is collateral?
I'm,
I'm a somewhat Tom to see a few of you are going to end up borrowing money but
uh,
but as you haven't got trust fund,
you're gonna end up borrowing money.
So what is collateral?
Let's say?
Yeah.
Yes.
What's collateral?
You give someone the whole ease.
You left the bank hold onto something,
right?
You let the bank hold on to something in the events,
in the event that you default on the loan.
All right,
you're going to let the bank hold on something in the event that you default on
the loan.
Now for most people here,
what are they going to post as flat as it?
Let's assume that we can,
we're back to our original contract here.
We can't,
we can't do this.
We're back to our original case.
What are most of you are going to end up using as collateral if you borrow
money?
Yeah,
everyone take a house.
I'm guessing that for most of you,
I'm not going to look around the room cause I don't know how many trust from bay
trust from babies I got in the room.
But for most of you it's going to be what?
It's going to your parents' house.
All right.
All right,
so why?
Why is it that your parents house being posted as collateral is going to prevent
you from disappearing to Mexico with the loan?
Well,
let's have a look.
Has it changes the payoffs?
Now if you take the money and run,
you disappeared to Mexico,
but you end up with $1 minus a house here and $3 minus the house.
That of course where we're lying here on you liking your parents.
Enough not to mind about the fact that we were sleeping in the rain,
but as long as that's the case along,
if that's the case with all PR,
I think with high probability you're now going to decide to return the loan at
least if you can.
Is that right now?
No,
just that the way in which this collateral works,
there's a subtlety to how this classical works.
You might think that the way in which collateral works is that now the lender
feels safer because even if you end up defaulting on the loan,
at least they get this house.
All right?
And that's true.
There's some truth in that,
but that's really not the key here,
right?
Frankly,
most bank lenders don't want your parents' house,
right?
Or your parents might have very nice houses,
but this isn't a good housing market right now and they didn't particularly want
to see your parents on the streets.
The way in which this works is not,
not so much that it gives an extra positive return to the lender.
The way in which it works is it gives an extra negative return to the borrower.
All right,
let's just do this backward induction again with the house in place.
so with this house in place as before,
you'll return the loan up here,
but now provided you'd like your parents enough.
You would also return the loan here cause you'll prefer $2 to your two to $3
minus your parents' house,
in which case you'll get a loan of three.
All right?
All right.
So the way in which the collateral worked was by hurting you enough in the Ed,
or in this case,
I go parents enough in the event of default in such a way as to change your
behavior,
but notice it helps you.
So here's a subtlety coming in here.
By issuing collateral,
we actually lowered the payoff of the borrower,
had certain end points of the tree.
We lowered the payoff of the borrower at certain end points of the tree.
But as a consequence,
we were able to end up at an outcome
that was better for the borrower.
Sometimes having lower payoffs can actually make you better off.
And the reason that it makes you better off is it changes the behavior of other
players in the game in such a way as it may.
It may benefit you in this example by by inducing the lender to give you a
bigger loan.
All right?
So the way the collateral works is it lowers,
yeah.
Louis,
your payoffs
if you do not repay.
Oh,
but it leads to you being better off.
Yeah.
And the reason it makes you better off is it changes.
It changes the choices of others,
change the choices of others in a way,
in a way that helps you.
All right?
We're going to see lots of examples of that in the next couple of days.
All right.
No,
collateral is an example.
We what have incentive design collateral is also an example of something larger.
The larger thing is the idea of commitments.
Collateral is a commitment strategy.
It's a commitment strategy.
It commits you to repaying the loan.
All right.
I want to give another example of a commitment strategy.
I can think.
I think the idea of commitment's important one,
and we have just about time to do,
right?
So I wanted it to go completely away from the context of our lender borrower
game a second and look somewhere else entirely.
All right.
I'm gonna get rid of this for now.
I want to take us back to a 10 66
okay.
What happened in 10 66
What happened in 10 66 I know.
I know what he does in America and no one gets an indication anymore,
but still what I've been in 10 66,
the Norman conquest took place in 10 66.
Right?
So the norm and army invades from Norman be led by William the conqueror and
lands on the Sussex speeches at Hastings.
All right.
And what I want to imagine is a game involving the normal army or William the
conqueror in particular,
and the Saxon Army.
All right?
So here's the little game.
So we're now in the,
when they were in the area of medieval military strategy.
All right,
and here is the game.
we'll start with the Saxons here.
The Normans have already invaded.
So I guess I guess the normal,
I've already moved it moved.
But here's the,
uh,
here's the sacs.
Now me making a decision.
They're deciding
between,
uh,
fighting and the important medieval military,
a military tactic known as running away.
And of course the Normans.
I got to know whether the Saxons are actually going to charge down the beach and
attack them and they are going to have to decide whether to fight or run away.
All right?
And let's put the pay offs now.
Leave some space below here.
Leave some space down here on your notes.
All right?
That's what the payoffs in.
So I'm going to put the northern payoffs first and the Saxon payoff second.
Okay.
Norman payoffs first.
Saxon payoff second.
All right,
the pay offs are going to be like,
like,
like this.
If both,
if both sides fights,
a lot of people are not dead and we'll call that zero zero.
If the sanctions fight on the Normans,
runaway,
the Saxons get to in the Normans get one because at least they're alive.
If the sanctions runaway in the Normans fights,
then uh,
the new,
uh,
New Orleans get to and the Saxons get one in.
Just flip things around.
And if Bruce lots runaway,
then ultimately it's good for the Saxons.
Alright,
so this is the gate.
All right,
let's be careful.
I've put the Sax and pay off second the Sax and pay off the second.
If we analyze this game,
my backward induction,
we can see that the Normans are in trouble.
Why are the normals in trouble?
Because if they are tagged by the Saxons than fighting yields zero and running
away yields one.
So they're to run away.
And conversely,
if the Saxons runaway,
then in fact the Normans,
we'll stay in fights because it's easy to stay and fight against people who are
running away.
Even I can do that.
Alright,
so that's uh,
so they're going to go for two rather than one.
But now the Saxons face this choice.
They know that if they attack the Normans,
the Normans will run away.
And the Saxons we'll get to,
but if the facts and run away,
then the Normans will stay and fight or the Saxons will only get one.
So the Saxons are gonna end up fighting.
All right.
I want to see how we did the backward induction.
So this is not a good situation if you happen to be the Norman commander,
if you're the guy who led these troops across the channel,
all right,
so what did William the conqueror do?
He burned his ships,
right?
So let's now make this game a little bit more like the real historical
situation.
Here's a move that William the conqueror,
the king of the of the Normans can do.
He can either not burn his ships
or he can burn them
if he burns them.
Then the game is rather different.
Once again,
the Saxons can decide whether to fight or run away,
but now the Normans really don't have any choice.
They have to stay and fight because swing back to from swearing armor is
difficult.
All right,
so the payoffs zero,
zero and two one as before.
All right,
so we know now that the normal is going to stay and fight.
That's all that's available to them.
I've,
I've put it that they hit that even have the option of,
of running away.
If you wanted,
you could put running away yield to them in a minus infinity or whatever it is
to get drowned.
All right,
so now if the Saxons,
if,
if the Normans have burned the boats,
the sanctions knew that if they fight the Saxons,
we'll get zero.
If they run away,
they'll get minus one.
So now they'll run away.
And then from,
from William the conqueror,
his point of view,
what you choosing between,
he knows that if he doesn't burn his boats,
the Saxons,
we'll fight and his troops will run away.
But if he does burn his boats,
the Saxons were runaway and his troops were fights.
So he wants to burn his boats.
All right,
everyone.
Okay with example,
all right.
Now this is probably the classic example of our commitment strategy,
William the conqueror and this example,
or Cortez and hatch,
the more famous example,
burn the boats to get rid of some strategies to get rid of some choices all
together.
And you might think,
how can get reading?
How can getting rid of choices make me better off?
And the reason in a game is picked a sequential game.
But the game generally,
the reason getting rid of can make me better off is it changes the behavior of
people on the other side of the game in such a way as benefits me.
In this particular example,
it makes the other side less likely to fight.
All right?
So once again,
this is a commitment.
It's a commitment.
And the way it works is this example of a commitment is actually to have fewer,
to have fewer options.
Yeah,
fewer options and it changes.
It changes the behavior
of others.
We didn't change the behavior of others.
It wouldn't be worth doing.
So let's just talk about this a little bit more.
There's another famous example of a military commitment strategy,
uh,
that occurs in the movie Dr. Strange love.
How many of you have seen the movie doctor strange love?
How many even not seen the movie doctor?
Strange love.
All right,
good homework.
Exercise for the weekend.
Rent the movie,
Dr. Strange up.
Great.
It's very good movie.
All right.
Stanley Kubrick,
I think.
All right.
So in the doc in doctor strange love,
there's a famous commitment strategy.
What is the famous commitment strategy in Doctor Strangelove?
Somebody has going to Mike,
uh,
can get a mic down here that there's one on the way.
The guy in White's,
I go,
there you go.
Yep.
There you go.
Great.
Lose radio contact with the base,
which means that they're going to end up dropping the bomb are that's true.
I was thinking more a more deliberates what was that?
One of the more deliberate,
the guy in red at,
what did that in red here.
Here we go.
Try the Soviet constructed doomsday device.
So if their attack,
they automatically launched their,
all of their nuclear weapons goods.
Good.
So the worry that the Soviets have is they think the Americans might attack them
and they worry that the Americans might attack them thinking that they won't
retaliate because they weren't ever really have an incentive to retaliate once
their citizens are destroyed.
So they construct a device,
they call the doomsday device that will automatically launch nuclear missiles
back on the Americans if the Russians are attacks.
All right.
It's a commitment.
It's a commitment device to make it credible that they will actually respond.
Were they,
were they to be attacked by the crazy Americans?
All right,
so there's a mistake,
however,
that the Russians make.
What is the mistake that the Russians make?
The mistake?
The Russians make a tie.
We here,
the guy in the yellow sweatshirt here,
they don't tell anyone about the machine,
right?
They don't tell the Americans that they built the doomsday device.
All right?
So this is really an important idea hidden in.
It's really a great movie.
Commitment strategies are a good idea.
They can make things credible,
but the only reason that having fewer strategies is good you is because it
changes the behavior on the other side.
In this case,
it behave.
It changes the behavior of the Saxons.
It doesn't work.
If the other side doesn't know about it,
why?
It's crucial that the other side knows.
So the other players,
Moss,
Miss Nadeau.
All right,
just to hammer this home,
notice that the expression in the English language is burning your boats.
It's not going over to your boats and just as quietly drilling little holes in
them,
right?
It's burning your boats.
You want the other side to see this big bonfire on the beach and to know that
the boats are no longer available
as in doctor strange love.
It's crucial and it's a terrible mistake for the Russians not to tell the
Americans that they've built this machine.
Alright,
alright,
so knowledge here is crucial knowledge of the other side.
Now I should just complete the history of this.
This didn't work.
In the case of the battle of Hastings,
the Saxons attacked anyway and it just turned area.
There was a big blog book,
blood bath and the Normans really only won this battle because somebody's got a
lucky,
lucky shot and hit their hit kit,
King Harold in the eye,
so they actually know this is a good story.
We didn't as a,
as a monitor,
a tactic,
not a,
and I'll actually a true story and I do that.
I'm adding that in because otherwise they're going to get hundreds of letters
from people who watch the video.
All right.
Now we've got a bunch of lessons today,
but I'm not done.
I want to play one more game.
Before I do though,
I want to make sure we understand.
We're gonna play another games every stay put.
I want to make sure that there's a bunch of lessons on the board and I wanted
you to understand what's important and what's more important.
Everything is important,
but somethings are more important.
All right?
So the idea of commitment is an important idea and the idea of incentive design
is an important idea,
but there's one idea here that is more important than anything else.
And that idea is backward induction.
All right?
What else?
Son rounded.
Okay.
How important is backward induction?
I couldn't.
Induction is the most important thing I'm going to teach you in the second half
of the,
of the semester.
It's probably the most important thing I'm gonna teach you in the whole
semester.
And it may be the most important thing you're gonna learn at Yale.
All right?
How it,
it's the onset of all questions.
If I asked you a question and as happens from time to time you've been sleeping
in cars and you wake up startled because I've now asked you a question and that
camera is on you,
right and you don't know what the question is,
then the answer is backward induction.
All right,
I'm stressing this because six weeks from now,
whatever it is in December,
there's going to be a final exam.
I guarantee now that there will be a question on the final exam that involve
backward induction and I guarantee that at least one person in the room,
well forget to solve it.
My backward induction.
All right,
so all you're going to use backward induction on the final exam.
Yes,
you're all going to remember it.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Now we'll play one more game just for fun.
All right,
well before we pay,
when we get getting read and I'll do one of the things.
Sorry,
one other thing before we pay that one more game.
I apologize.
Um,
the one thing I want to do here is,
uh,
I put up a tree here,
but I forgot to tell you anything about the tree.
This was a tree.
And I would be,
I would be remissed if I didn't tell you a few things about trees.
So there's a certain amount of jargon that goes along with trees,
and I want you to go to read the textbook and know what that jargon is.
So these spots,
he's dose in the tree.
These things are called nodes,
all right?
They're called nodes.
And in fact,
the end points of the tree where the payoffs are,
these are also called mode,
but they're called end nodes,
all right?
And these branches and the tree,
the brushes are,
they are,
the branches are called ages.
All right?
So tree consists of nodes,
edges,
and these missing endnote.
Missing dots are the end nodes.
The end nodes are associated with payoffs.
Do we need to write that?
That's obvious,
right?
That's to do with payoffs.
And every other node belongs to somebody who's chosen,
whose,
whose turn it is to make a decision at that node.
All right?
So there's these other nodes.
The ones on ed nodes are called decision those.
Yeah,
and it's perfectly possible,
for example,
in our Norman conquest game for somebody to have several nodes,
somebody could move once and then later on in the game,
I may also be noted that it never reached.
And again,
one last piece of jargon I route through a tree from the beginning to an end is
called a path,
a path,
a way of getting through the tree from the beginning to the end.
So I have a pop quiz on that jargon later and now it's play.
The last game I wanna play,
we've got 10 minutes,
right?
Okay.
Everyone understand the jargon?
I want to play a game now,
right?
So the game we're gonna play is a game.
We're going to call the hungry lion game.
All right?
It's the hungry lion game.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm going to pick on a,
a row of the clause,
actually gonna pick on this row of the class.
All right?
And this row of the class,
everyone can see this row crop bag.
You're leaned over the balcony,
this row of the clause.
We're going to imagine that everybody in this row is a lion.
All right?
They're all,
they all look like lions.
Not much,
but never been.
Pretend they're lions,
right?
Suspension of disbelief.
All right?
They're all lions and they're all hungry.
I accepts except for one person.
Who's this guy at the end whose name is Alex?
So Alex is a sheep.
Alex,
how's the MS?
I had the misfortune of wondering into this pack of pride,
pride of lions,
and is liable to get eaten because they're hungry.
All right?
However,
one thing stands between Alex,
Alex,
the sheep,
and being eaten.
The one thing that stands between him and being an Eaton is that in Lyons
society,
the only lion who is allowed to eat the sheep is the headline.
The Big Lion whose name is Ryan,
right?
Ryan is the headline here,
alright,
only Ryan can eat addicts.
The sheep.
No other lion can.
He acts the sheep.
All right?
Now there's a catch.
If I,
if I,
if Ryan Eats Alex,
if Ryan the lion eats out at the sheep,
the coaches that if Ryan the lion eats ice for sheep,
then Ryan,
the lion will fall into a postprandial stupor,
fall asleep.
At which point,
the second largest lion who's name is Chris,
Chris can eat Ryan a neurosis.
Chris can never eat the sheep.
He can only ever eat the lion,
the big lion,
and only then if a lion is eating the sheep and falls asleep,
it's very strict,
right?
Lions society is very hierarchical like England.
All right,
right,
right.
If,
however Ryan the lion eats Alex the sheep and is then eaten,
falls asleep and isn't eaten by Crystal Lion,
then and only then he will fall into a stupor when which point he can be eaten
by Isabella Isabella,
who's the third largest line and so on.
Every understand the game.
All right.
No questions.
No talking among yourselves.
Write down what you would do if you were our key decision maker.
Who is Ryan Ryan the light?
Well,
before we'd write it down,
can I get Alex to stand up a second?
Stand up.
All right.
The camera on him,
right?
This is,
this is the menu.
All right?
All right.
Thank you.
Okay.
So you have to write down on your notepad whether you Ryan,
the lion in Ryan's,
um,
shoes or pause or whatever,
whether you would eat addicts,
the sheep,
and we've written something down.
All right?
Now this,
let's ask grind the lion what he's gonna do.
So Ryan,
are you going to eat Alex the sheep?
No,
he says no,
he's not going to eat.
Why not?
Cause then I'll shout out,
shout out.
Then I'd be eating as well,
but it'd be eating what I see if he would have been eaten.
So how do Eaton rx the sheep then he would have fallen asleep and then he'd been
in danger of being eaten by,
by Chris.
Chris,
would you have eaten Ryan?
Nah.
So he wouldn't have eaten him and fats in fights.
It looks like Ryan would've got a free lunch.
Right?
And only no free lunches.
Economics.
Something's wrong.
All right.
Uh,
and what,
why is Chris worried about it?
Chris?
He's worried about it because Chris,
because Chris is worried about Isabella Isabella eating him and what am I doing
wrong?
What's wrong with this analysis?
By the way,
before you see what's wrong,
how many of you,
how many of you in Ryan shoes would have eaten that the sheep and how many of
you would not have in the sheet?
Okay,
what am I doing wrong?
I'm in totally the wrong part of the room.
I shouldn't be here at all,
right?
I shouldn't be a toll in this part of the classroom.
I can't get round.
Wait a second.
Excuse me.
All right,
I should be okay.
Which row is my,
where my lions.
Where's my lion row?
A QBO.
I should be way over here with the baby lion.
Who's name is.
Hey,
gay egg has a little baby lion.
Very cute,
but a gay if you get to chose to eat is going to eat.
Why is he going to eat?
Cause there's no one to eat him.
All right,
have anger gets the chance to eat.
The second law is the second baby and his name is John.
John.
That egg and we'll eats.
All right.
So if John gets a chance to eat Ben,
Ben is John gonna eat badge now Jonny,
you gonna eat band?
No.
John's not going to eat band because John knows he'll get eaten by gay.
So Ben,
if you get a chance to eat,
Vidar,
are you going to eat?
You're gonna eat Virta wait a second.
Wait a second.
So we don't,
we just argued that if you eat,
then the second largest line whose name was John John is not going to eat.
Yes.
Okay.
So we have,
we know that it looks lions going to eat.
So the second leg of this line is not going to eat.
So the 3rd of July and can eat safely.
So the fourth of US lion should not eat right.
So the fifth that was lion should eat.
We've got eats,
eats not at EADS.
Eat,
not eat,
eat,
eat the rice.
That right.
So in fact,
you should have eaten him.
More important point is,
how should we analyze this game?
What was should we have used?
Paquin induction.
How many of you use backward induction?
Be Honest.
How many of you,
so what's the point here?
The point,
the point is this,
five minutes ago I said,
the most important thing you'll ever learn at Yale is backward induction.
Then I distracted you with some fairly irrelevant nonsense
and five minutes later,
nobody used backward induction to the main lesson from today that it's we're
going to pick up on Wednesday is to use something.
What are we going to use?
All right,
we'll see you on Wednesday.